I always say I'm not gonna do it this
time I'm not I don't need it we're not
we're not gonna do it well then here we
are at it again does not approve I'm
just gonna close my eyes and pretend
that I'm not here all these empty faces
talk about problems I don't care I can't
wait til sundown just my body's aching I
just wanna dance I just wanna dance it's
not the most flattering or best angle
but it's all we've got to work with
because there's no time to waste
we must sending you a link our bait
don't you wanna party do you wanna party
hey guys we're off to the Apple store
there was a time once when I said I will
never be first in line for an Apple
product and then that all changed and
promise you that I will never be the
first person in line for any sort of
apple of it
justine where are all your crazy friends
with you this morning I really only
asked Jenna just sit with me I don't
think all the coffee in the world could
have convinced her to come here today I
technically I'm only really waiting for
an hour this is just silly
[Music]
the street now so no problem
but I'll just sit in it anyway because
I've got some time to heal
so usually the Apple store opens at 10
o'clock I had high hopes that it's gonna
open at 8:00 is usually for new phones
or product launches they do open early I
may be waiting outside in front of the
to order an iPhone on my iPhone
like I've never said I'm proud of this
thing is if I'm able to get a perimeter
that I'll just go home and come back and
because my pre-order it's had at this
point I might as well just sit here and
what else our afternoon mocha mocha
sugar I want to talk to a person
[Music]
Siri what is the temperature right now
it's 51 degrees right now feels like
three all of the people that I thought
were waiting in line it was like oh cool
there's some other people here they
worked here at they were waiting to get
into the store because they were going
to work day no one stayed on one
nothing's happening like can you believe
this
alright well they're preparing my order
so they'll email me when it's ready for
pickup so I'm gonna go home
are you doubtful sir I'll see you later
first in line for red iPhone don't
forget it
I might have went home but I got in line
just a pre-order just in case I didn't
get one
[Music]
while I wait for what email confirmation
that says Justine your red iPhone is
ready I'm setting up to shoot the
unboxing okay Melissa Stuart from that
offer now of course the batteries are
dead
these batteries die so quick in these
cameras it's crazy but got a studio in
my office and I'm shouting okay that's
good I like that's what I like what do
you think about this do you know what
this is Maddie look at what I'm going to
be wearing last year for you to rewind
they sent out really awesome jackets for
everybody that was in it
I've been reading to make a video about
this for quite some time but I never did
little man little man you remember the
man hey what's it like living with with
me do you like it
that's what you like Mike was a high-end
camera well he's trying to get a USB
cable I just got the excellent units
that my phone is ready for pickup it's a
story man what time is it it's 938 so
how many times have I walked down these
steps and said
we get to the Apple store here we are
[Music]
get the case
a white piece also my other one
[Music]
we're almost ready to go picking up
other phone case there's a new one that
came out it's a new
it's called berry but it actually wasn't
on the floor yet so they're right now
searching downstairs trying
hopefully
it will be underway
[Music]
Swifter up
hello hey what do you guys think of this
red iPhone where it is yet what do you
think real smudgy sorry my little finger
well I have a red phone I like it I like
it a lot oh it's it's nice but wait what
I'm confused because but wait I have a
red food too here well this is the red
red phone and this is when you look at
that what color like what type of thing
do you hint maybe like think about a
fruit Oh cherry uh yeah it's fine you
guys like a simple berry what about like
a light cherry I always get so many
compliments on my red case which I'm
like it's a basic red case but what if
they would have made it the same color
is the case well I really missed you at
the Apple Store today when I went and
camped out for no reason at all if I
would have showed up at 7 a.m. to camp
out with you ok but to be fair I was
afraid that I wouldn't be able to get a
pre-order and then I'd have to camp out
anyway so whatever we got the phone I'm
still debating what I want to do with it
do I want to keep it do I not
I haven't transferred over any of my
stuff yet because I'm feeling a little
skeptical but I'm not sure it's one of
those things where it looks incredible
without a case but for me I gotta have a
case I just don't like the way the white
face if you guys haven't checked out the
unboxing feel free to go check it out
and this is many many hours Wow Wow
did he puke or what I think that was
some toy aggression they also have some
other red accessories Apple watch band a
really cool iPhone charger and some
other cool stuff so check it out I'll
see you guys later I'm gonna go and I'm
gonna actually be editing this video
right now so tell you that right now we
got the phone guys I don't feel other
red goodies - this is not a part of this
is one of my favorite vlogging tripods
it's incredible not a part of this
unboxing so things are gonna be checking
out today we've got the red Apple watch
band we've got